محمد الحسن نلبات مدير ديوان رئيس مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي اهلا بك السيد محمد قبل
الانتقال الخرطوم انتقاد رئيس المفوضيه هل
بشرتم اتصالات مع اطراف الخلافه السودان
نعم المجلس مجلس السلم والامن هذا
الافريقي عقد اجتماعا طارئا
سريعا امس باديس ابابا
وقرر من بين بعض الاجراءات والمواقف ان
يكلف ان يطلب الاحرار السيد رئيس المفوضيه
محمد بان يسافر في اسرع وقت ممكن الى
الخرطوم
لبذل كل المساعي لدى الاطراف من اجل ان
يوقف القتال بصوره سريعه وبدون اي شرط
والرجوع الى طاوله المفاوضات والحوار
الهادئ بينهما
تفاديا لدمار السودان
والحاق اكبر الاضرار بشعبه وبامن ام الامه
السودانيه
المنطقه والقاره بصوره عامه ولكن لما تم
هذا التقرير وتجهز السيد
رئيس المفوضيه ومفوض الامن
والسلم السيد بانكولي ليذهب الى الخرطوم
اعترضت عارضه وهي ان المطار غير صالح مطار
الخرطوماني غير صالح البته حتى الان لنزول
الطائرات وكل الرحلات معلقه وقد تكون لحقت
به بعض الاضرار وحسب المعلومات المتوفره
لدينا لحد الساعه انه في منطقه غير امنه
لقرب
الصراع المسلحي منها ولربما فيها
وحالما تكون هنالك اي صالحه مهما كان
ضيقها سينتقل بحول الله هذا الوفد رفيع
المستوى
من الاتحاد الافريقي لبذل كل المساعي من
اجل الهدف اني في الذكر طيب اذا سيد موسى
فكي لن ينتقل قريبا الى الخرطوم لحدوث هذا
المشكل ان المطار غير جاهز لاستقبال سيد
موسى فكي
هذا هو السبب الوحيد واتصالات مع الاطراف
قائمه من اجل التحضير
للزياره وحالما يتم التغلب على هذه النقطه
الفنيه اليس هناك مطارات بديله سيد محمد
نحن ننظر في كل هذه الاختيارات لحد الساعه
ننظر في هذه الاختيارات لحد الساعه اذا
العائق الوحيد هو فقط عائق
وليس هناك سبب اخر
ليس بل امن بالتحديد
هو يتوفر مطار ممكن ان تحط به طائره سواء
كانت من الخطوط العاديه او خطوط
فوق العاده يعني
هل اجريتم اتصالات اوليه مع اطراف النزاع
وماذا قيل لكم
نعم في اتصالات من من امس
والبارح وهذا الصباح هي قائمه هل لم يريد
ان ادخل في تفاصيلها ولكنها قائمه نفهم
ذلك نفهم ذلك فقط ربما تحسس النوايا هل
لمستم استعداد للوصول الى حل على الاقل
لايقاف اطلاق النار
واجلاء المدنيين واسعاف المدنيين
لم نتطرق بعد
للمضامين ما زلنا في على مستوى الاجراءات
العمليه لوصول الوفد الى
وتحديد الترتيبات الكفيله بوصوله بسرعه
قصوى
بالحد الادنى من الامن طيب لا نريد منكم
ان تعطونا مواقف اعرف هذا المساله صعبه
ولكن هل لمستم لدى الطرفين رغبه في ايجاد
حل
هنالك كثير من من الاراء في الساحه
السودانيه
ولا اود ان ادخل في تفاصيلها ولكن الراي
الغالب في السودان ونحن نتابع الوضع الكذب
ورغبه الشعب والنخب
كلها في ان تحقن الدماء وان يتوقف الصراع
العسكري وان تحلل الامور بصوره سلميه
ونرجو ان يتاكد هذا التوجه ليعم وليفرض
نفسه على كل من يعارض او يقاوموا حتى الان
ما يجري في الميدان يقول بان كل طرف يذهب
باتجاه الحسم عسكريا
ما التصور لديكم كمفوضيه لربما الوصول
لنتيجه
نحن نرى ان لا فائده في اللجوء الى العنف
ونرى ان كل حل عسكري مهما اعطى
نقطه في الصراع لهذا الطرف او ذاك لن يشكل
حلا نهائيا للازمه العميقه في البلاد ولن
ينفذ الى جذورها وبالتالي فالمصلحه تقتضي
بكل المعاني ان يتوقف الاقتتال بسرعه
وبدون شرط وان يرجع كل الاطراف عسكريون او
مدرينا الى طاوله المفاوضات
لتخليص البلاد من الطامه الكبرى التي
اوقعها في هذا الصراع طيب سيد محمد بما
ذكرته بحدوث هذا العذر الامني عدم الذي لا
يمكن فريق المفوضيه من النزول في مطار
الخرطوم هذا يوحينا الى سؤال الوقت الى اي
مدى الوقت والتدخل سريعا مهم في لملمه
الوضع بالنسبه للمفوضيه
نحن نسعى بكل الوسائل وبالتنسيق مع
شركائنا ايضا في القاره اولا لاننا
نحبذ ان يكون الحل حلا افريقيا سودانيا
سودانيا بالدعم الافريقي وان يبقى في اطار
القاره وفي هذا الصدر تعرفون ان الايجاز
قررت ارسال ثلاث رؤساء ايضا لنفس الغرض
ولكنهم لم يحلوا بعد في الخرطوم قد
تعترضهم نفس المشكله قد يكونوا وجد لها حل
عند دخول
لقاعه الجزيره هنا في اديس ابابا ولكننا
عاكفون على ان نجد حلا سريعا لاننا لا
نريد الا ان نبذل كل طاقاتنا من اجل
دعم التوجه
الداعي الى ايقاف اطلاق النار والى الرجوع
الى طاوله المفاوضات هل هناك
ترحيب من الطرفين لهذا المجهود او المسعه
الافريقي
لما يتلقى حتى الان الا مواقف ايجابيه
وقد تتضح الامور عندما نحل بالخرطوم ان
شاء الله في اقرب وقت ممكن هل لك ان تصرح
قليلا من فكره الترحيب او الايجابيه في
التعاطي مع هذا التحرك الافريقي ما الذي
يعني ذلك
يعني انه على العموم الرئيس سائد في
البلاد يدعو الى ان الاتحاد الافريقي يلقي
بثقل في
الشان من اجل المساعده في ايقاف الاقتتال
بين الاشقاء والرجوع الى الحوار البناء من
اجل انقاذ البلد تقول الراي السائد في
البلاد ولم تذكر الطرفين بالاسم
انا اعتقد انهم يندرجان في الراي السائد
ولكن الخلاف والمشكله فقط ان شاء الله
تفضل
هل الترحيم من قبل الاحزاب السياسيه ام من
قبل قائد الجيش او قائد الدعم السريع سيد
محمد
فنحن لا نريد ان ندخل بهذه التفاصيل لحد
الساعه طبعا هذا يهمنا ان نعرف ما يهم
المشاهد السوداني ان يعرف لان المشهد معقد
جدا في السودان لذلك اي شرح قد يفيد في
اجلال هذه الصوره المركبه والمعاقده سيد
محمد انا
ارى
الناس
ونعمل املا عميقا في ان توسل جهود كل
الخيرين من السودانيين اولا ومن الافارقه
ثانيا ومن اصدقائي السودان الخله ثالثا
طيب في ان استغل كيف سريعا دمار السودان
والرجوع ببنيها الى طريق
بانك تعرف الاشياء السوداني بشكل جيد هل
تتوقع ان يكون هذا المجهود الافريقي مثمرا
ذلك املي
واملنا جميعا شكرا لك السيد محمد حسن
اللباط مدير ديوان رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي من اديس ابا شكرا جزيلا لك